holy the fact this movie was
directed by Jordan Peele of Key & Peele
Rubin we understand of a doubt that
funny people are really dark damaged
people on the inside in a beautifully
creative way pump to review as long as
do it
[Music]
get out so get out is written and
directed by Jordan Peele like I said of
Canfield
it's a horror slice thriller with comedy
in it at first and look as ordinary as
can be white girl dating a black dude
who the black dudes about to meet her
parents and her parents are super white
your practices all things just like my
parents are awkwardly white we're going
to get through this though and when he
finally gets there and they meet the
movie does a really good job at
addressing passive racism like a baby
showed up it was all in your face like
the dad runs out with a shotgun all the
boy wearing a confederate flag t-shirt
me like I know exactly where this is
going but the movies way more subtle
than that it just like that it's a
really passive racism of racist people
who don't know the reason it's just like
oh that's great you're in college school
there's a basketball scholarship you're
like so in that it's an interesting
social commentary that has you locked in
just like oh that's really relevant
then when the movie flips and becomes a
thriller horror movie
you're already locked into it you are
there now and you ain't going anywhere
because it's a really intense movie the
movie is really unsettling at how
completely passive aggressive things are
competitive aggressive people are the
worst if someone's just aggressive you
know where they're coming from if
they're smiling in your face in a
passive aggressive way and they have
inner monologues you're not hearing and
they're not letting out I find that to
be more disturbing people are hiding
they got secrets I don't like that
and that really is the backbone of all
the family and friends in here this dude
has the meat and yet when I'm thinking
about the movie there really was a lot
of spinning around and talking and
interaction and I want to say the movies
a slow burn but I don't want to because
it didn't feel like a slow burn you know
when people say well the movie with a
slow burn what they mean is hey guys I
was pretty bored for a lot of it but by
the end it paid off I wasn't bored in
this movie I was completely fascinated
with the interaction and the people
figuring out what those people are
hiding figuring out how he's dealing
with it what he's thinking is he putting
the pieces together all the performances
were great whatever does the main dude
in this movie is going to be in Black
Panther I was like Oh rad the main girl
was really good in this movie there's a
lot of cast I didn't recognize one dude
I did it took a scene for me to be like
where have I seen that dude here it is
here's him in cabin in the woods
here's him now I feel like it's dude
ages 20 years in about five there's a
bridge in the space-time continuum what
can I say i dude pulled from the future
and the main friend who really isn't in
the movie a lot except for phone calls
he was awesome too he reminded me of
Michael Pena that he has that Michael
Pena
quality about it I want to see more that
dude in fact I want to see more of
everybody in this movie guys get out
with dark it was creepy it was
unsettling it was eerie it was relevant
in his racial social commentary that
does use it as a platform to make an
effective thriller I was biting my nails
in this movie walked out with a smile on
my face like that was surprisingly good
I will say get out is definitely worth
watching and definitely worth buying on
blu-ray
alright guys so get out have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's a
surprising thriller you thought would
suck but didn't suck whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]